okay chairman online
well good evening everyone and welcome
to the meeting of torres district
council
external overview and scrutiny committee
on the 21st of april
thank you for attending and watching
whether you're on the committee whether
you're a councillor joining us
or whether you're a member of the public
um
well just to start the meeting just
recognizing a really sad day for our
sovereign
her first birthday for many many years
without the partner she had and i'd just
like to
record the great service they've done
for our country over the time and put
that on the minute here today
i must be hard for her for her first
time
for many many years to to not have to
share
not to share be able to share it with
her beloved husband so we record um
birthday wishes to our majest her
majesty
and wish her well um as she comes
through some difficult days
we come to the agenda tom do i need to
read
any special rules um no it's fine chair
we can go
move straight on to item one we can go
straight on to item one
then we go to mary can you give us
apologies for absent please item number
one
yes chair we have apologies from
councillor cottle hankin and apologist
from councillor ford
okay so so that's uh and we're missing
council harding are we at the present
moment as well
that's correct can we just then go
through
the uh just go through a roll call if we
can just to make sure
okay i'll admit council kottelhanken and
councillor ford
councillor harding council hawkins
yeah yeah thank you councillor langford
present
pennington president
thank you so just seven attendees
yeah we've got seven attendees and we
are six to be court if i remember
rightly and i know
you are um leaving because you
unfortunately had such a clash of
meetings i know you're a tremendous
servant of this committee and i do
understand thank you for letting me know
um i hope you we can um keep going
through the situation
um and keep core we need to be six
members so we'll bear that in mind as we
go now bearing
that in mind and i understand we have no
public participants
waiting to speak tom that's correct
so we can pass on straight through
agenda item number three
would i can i ask permission of the
committee that we
put the minutes agenda item two
and the action missed agenda item four
um after sean may is spoken
and presented about the youth schemes
that are going on with petrol college
um do i need to take a vote stacy or can
we just do it by a show of hands here
you take a vote to amend the agenda
chair okay then for
quickly i will propose that we uh amend
if
simon are you happy with that because i
know that you've got a goal and uh
you know i'm very happy with that keep
going keep going can you second then
simon
yeah i will i'll second that okay in a
second then uh let's quickly take the
rope for mary if we can
yes cancel hot sorry council hawkins
yes councillor langford
councillor
mckenzie or kelson newton
paul councillor pennington
mr topham thank you
okay now agenda item number five
declaration of interest um you'll know
the score
uh from that point of view and so
we'll come to each item if there is you
will flag that up as per normal
there is no part to agenda item number
six no part
two so uh we have no need of an
agreement
i have no urgent matters under agenda
item number seven to be brought forward
uh so that is dealt with
anybody else but anything is urgent any
officer or
member member officer either way right
to be fair i don't see any hands going
out so we finished with that
so um before we start with petra uh
and sean mcnay i just like from the
council's point of view that we all
introduce ourselves
so that um sean can know what sort of
constituency we represent in what area
we come from just a sentence
from each of us about where we come from
my name is phil pennington i'm chair of
the committee
and um i've been on councils in 2007.
um on the edge of buddy third but very
interested also in the rural community
um so i pass on to uh
carl hawkins will be the next one on the
list to just uh introduce himself please
oh yes um yeah councillor hawkins um
i've got a daughter that's a pet truck
and she's loving it so um
good yeah there's a little bit of a mix
up at the moment with some people i'm
sure we'll get that sorted
i'll come and give you i'll give you a
call if you get stuck but
yeah um no she she it's been really good
for her
so thank you you've got a real interest
and uh
coaching watkins uh coachella langford
hi uh coaster shirley langford
representing the award for benefit south
uh coaster chris lover yes hello
everybody councillor chris leather i
represent northam ward i'm on northern
town council as well as the district
council
and our chair torridge's plans committee
as well thank you
great thank you simon newton uh
yes i'm simon newton i represent winkley
ward
um so very rare award and
one of the furthest wards from the
epicenter of biddeford
and we have a non-elected member in phil
topham
and phil puts an awful lot of work on
this committee um
but he um he's not elected he comes as
independent to bring a broader or
wider aspect to the meeting which has
been very very valuable
they'll introduce your background and uh
and just say a few words about yourself
and why you decided to put yourself
through this meal
as being a non-elected independent
independent member
well thank you chair i think you've
given a fairly a pretty fair description
of what i do i i joined the committee
because i thought it was something given
my
professional background it was something
that i could contribute to
and uh yes okay we have a couple of
three other that are not on the
committee and nick laws do you want to
just say a quick word he's always
attending this committee
yes i was on it last year and i miss it
terribly
now i i i represent westwood ho
and uh yeah i've heard nothing but good
things about petrol
okay councillor hodgson
hello i'm claire hodson i'm the board
member for um
westford hill alongside my colleague
councillor laws
and i also sit on northern town council
and finally our leader ken james
thank you chair well um you all know me
i'm ken james
i represent tamar side and milton
which is right down here almost on the
cornish border most of it
um and i'm pleased just to listen in and
if i don't get
later philip if this is your last one i
would just like to
add my thanks and appreciation for all
the work you've done
this chair of ons on the basis that
you've said you're standing down
but we've still got another week to go i
appreciate we have thank you very much
indeed
we have also from our officers the
principal officers
sorry i forgot
i was almost in tears chair um yeah
jamie mckenzie
represented biddeford eastward um
all three of my children have gone
through petroc and one is currently
lecturing at petroc
that would be nicola vandenbrook in
science technology engineering and maths
so that's right so you're going to hear
the truth tonight from sean mccain
[Laughter]
oh she loves loving it good okay
we've got um tom vanstone who's our
computer guy
and he does a wonderful job we've got
our solicitor to make sure we don't
break any rules
and mary who does all the work behind
the scenes so mary richard so um have i
missed anybody at all
nobody good feature
yes mary sorry sorry i just wanted to
have just received an email from council
harding saying he's having problems with
his internet and can't join
so i'll record his apologies recorded
apologies thank you mary thank you for
that
and um yes i've had internet problems
this morning as mary will know um
um we had to reboot the heavy thing and
got it going after a while so that was a
good get out after all
if i disappear i've got my ipad beside
me but you'll need to give me two
minutes to get the zoom
meeting going up on another contraption
here that's steampunk by the way
from that side so we come now then to
the agenda item number eight patrick
college promoting youth
employment um sean mccanney um thank you
for very much for coming along this
evening
we are listening to you know many much
on the news these days
about all the difficulties facing many
of our young people with exams
with apprenticeships with all the
training schemes the um
high youth unemployment around the area
etc etc
let me be clear my son james works up
with you at uh the college was a
personal interest just make sure that's
recorded as well so
it's not we've got um staff and um
students that working with you but we
seem to be all of us touching pet rock
at some point or other so
yeah we look forward very much to what
you've got to present to us
do you want us to keep going or do you
want us to ask questions as you're
presenting sure
i'm very happy for you to ask as you go
through i will
make a make some brief points in
relation to the topic but yeah
very happy to be interrupted okay fire
away
all yours and if you're going to hapa
state you might be corey so just bear
in mind that uh for
okay thank you ever so much uh chair i'm
just
clicking on to share um
which hopefully you can
[Music]
yeah we can see that sean that's good
i'm just gonna see
if you can still see it when i click
play from the start can you see it
all big now or has it disappeared
yeah we can we can see it but we can
still see the slide show down the
left-hand side as well
oh okay in which case i should probably
um
so i yeah i'll i'll i'll i'll use this
from here so um
in terms of the brief uh there was a bit
that you wanted to hear about
college mission and strategy we have um
uh so i'll say a little bit about that
um but
really interested in your questions that
you sent through thank you for that and
so i'll talk about
petroc and covid um the
impact that that's had um achievements
and issues
and um pick up those those questions
and then look at the future and our work
with uh uh positive council and the
college working in partnership
together and where that might take us
so i'll send these slides through of
course those are links to the documents
that i'm
talking to um and my contact details
um so petroc 2025 strategy this is a
strategy that you'll recall we um
consulted on widely um in the community
we involved our staff and
our learners um in inputting two and
uh our mission for the strategy
is excellence through learning now
petroc's been a
solidly good college both financially
and
on a learning basis for some time we've
been even in ofsted terms in um you go
back
10 years we were we we were outstanding
but we hadn't seen that
right across the piece we've got some
amazing provision in some areas but
um we need to produce the excellence
across the piece so that's our agenda
for the next five years
and people say well it isn't good good
enough
and yeah i say to my colleagues in in
the college you look at the prospects
for our young people
in our constituencies and you can see
that good isn't good enough for them we
need to have excellence to give them the
head start that they need
to um tackle some of the um to overcome
some of the issues that they face
um with us so that's our agenda um
staff really keen about we're values-led
organizations so
um the our strategy uh
shows our values of community
empowerment and respect
and those are um lived and real and we
we talk about those um
right through the strategy process in
terms of what that means for us
we also want to be known for um
five ways of working the team petroc
approach
uh you can see those there big focus on
personalization
for learners so that's not treating
people
um as numbers or cattle it's been very
much a
kind of a feature of their you know the
petrol community
and team approach that people come to um
uh
working around what are their specific
needs whether they're an adult whether
they're
a a 16 year old whether they have
special educational needs
um that we we look at what we can do for
them and similarly we provide
a number of services to um a range of
organizations
looking at our being customer focused
digitally able is
certainly a key thing as you would
expect for
any organization and um you know it's
impressive i think the way that
um we've all moved to kind of working uh
through this kind of mechanism but that
digitally able is also
about um for us around looking at the
predictive
power of big data analytics so that we
can
better support individuals to succeed
achieving value for money is key to us i
say every pound
not saved is a pound not spent
on creating that excellent learning
experience for our learners
so a big feast for us as i know is for
yourselves at
the council um we need to be agile and
entrepreneur or the kobit period has
shown us that as well
and underpinning all this as you might
expect
continuously learning and improving
every member of staff
showing what that learning is that
they're doing so that we
as a college can be continuing to
improve what we do
so um these are five aims um
happy to deal with questions around
these i say a little bit about each of
them
uh the
each of the aims supported by two uh two
objectives
um we have measurable key performance
indicators and a five-year trajectory
that we expect which is different for
each of those um
performance indicators benchmarked
against what outstanding is
in um within england so we're
benchmarking against
the top 10 of colleges in the country
as where we're aiming to get to and
showing the trajectory across that
so five areas first creating outstanding
learner achievement in all areas i say
we've got some outstanding
um provision our supported learning and
our special educational needs is
um outstanding provision one of the
things that people
often don't know about um petrol if
you take the proportion of our a-level
learners getting aab
which is one of the nationally available
um measures
we have the fourth best performance of
any general further education college in
the country
and so but our agenda here is about
making sure that every learner gets that
outstanding experience
transforming life chances and employment
prospects for all
this is at the heart i think some of the
challenges that we're facing at the
moment
um and the the your interest chair
around youth unemployment we are putting
employment at the heart of all of our
programs at every level right from entry
level through to our
degree level programs and
transforming life chances also about
making available opportunities
to uh people which they perhaps haven't
had
because of um experience or background
or
um or what have you so for instance you
know we have
um extending the international dimension
of our curriculum
within that we run one of the biggest um
outward
uh student mobility programs to do work
internationally
we know when the 11 of those learners
have never been out of the country
before they go on that program
and with us so when they come back their
um
attainment and the their persistence
their attention
is and attendance is is stronger than
those who um
who didn't go um that's one of those
dimensions
we're looking at that full piece of
saying okay everyone is going to succeed
here and so some people face particular
disadvantages
and we're going to be monitoring that
and making sure that we can and bring up
those
areas that are are not doing as well
to um the the college average um
building community and prosperity within
northern
and mid devon and the wider southwest of
england we have previously had
a provision subcontracted provision in
london and
elsewhere in the country our focus
where we will dedicate our our time our
management attention and our work
is within these areas and it is about
making sure that we help to
as it says build community and
prosperity um
in northern and mid devon and do
everything that we can in working in
partnership
on that agenda really important for our
communities
is this next uh role uh
you know people are familiar with
college's role in boosting um
skills and education but this is about
boosting the productivity innovation and
agility of the businesses and
organizations within
our um within our community
we know in northern devon that
we're not going to get a big um
multinational come and locate their
headquarters uh here
what we need to do is support our local
businesses
to innovate to understand how um
they can get on and also to support
people who create new businesses
um through entrepreneurship programs and
growing our own within our own community
and finally um as we say in the strategy
this probably isn't any agenda that's
more important and to
all of us at the moment than tackling um
climate
emergency we are doing that both
through our own agenda as an
organization
and we've set ourselves
a carbon reduction target we want to be
uh
carbon neutral by 2035 but for the next
five
year period we've set us as what our
trajectory is on that and we're
on um we're on track with that but also
and i think more importantly
um helping our learners and our staff
to understand how they can play a role
in tackling the climate emergency
as they go out into the world through
education so we have a
we will be making sure that every single
one of our programs supports the un
sustainable development goals
um through us revising our portfolio um
the uh
as i mentioned fairly straightforward um
objectives behind this as a trajectory
um over the five years standard thing
you would expect is that i'm sure you
scrutinize within the council driving
and tracking performance
and actively manage risks associated
with this because we live in quite a
volatile
environment we need to make sure that we
do that
so coming to the topic that you um you
picked up
around you know how has covert
experience
been for um petrogly as an organization
and for um our learners um
we adopted approach at the college
where we said we're going to create
a learning environment and a working
environment that is stable
sustainable and safe and so
stable we we were not wanting to
create something where people would be
in
and then would have to be um all kicked
out
and just their their learning um
disrupted and we wanted it to be
sustainable so that we would get that
learning right through and there
wouldn't be breaks in learning due to us
um losing stuff or disrupting things
and we've taken um
the our covert secure responsibilities
very
seriously as a college some other um
policies had not uh
been as um uh uh has taken the same
approach but we know from our
own analysis that in college
the infection rate was um one-seventh
of the community infection rate um that
existed um
within the area so that we have got a
a very secure approach to that because
we think it's about keeping our learners
safe it's about keeping our staff safe
and we carried our
our trade unions have been supportive of
this because but it's also more
importantly i think about
keeping their family safe and our
communities
safe and so you know there is a danger
that colleges
create um spreading opportunities and
we've been
um plans to make sure that we don't do
that
we um we developed with the university
of x actually a covered modeling app
that we made available
nationally we won a national award for
this this um
created epidemiological model where you
could put in your own local data
and um then use that to identify the
numbers of people who would be like to
be self-isolating and
and infected that's enabled us to
when we made changes to the way that we
um
we deliver our curriculum um we could do
it
knowing what the likely impact would be
so that we know that what we were doing
was um
safe for our learners for our staff so
we have had a
blended learning provision across the
course of the um
the year that has enabled us to
maintain that sustainable provision it
was key from learning from the modeling
um that if you had breaks away from the
college that that meant that you didn't
get a um infection build um
in the college typically um where we
have
cases the numbers of people who had to
self-isolate the
modal number that i had to self-isolate
with the case was zero
and because of the model that we're able
to because we practice social distancing
on
on-site um but that blended learning
provision
has um i think
also meant that our learners and
our staff have had to um develop
new skills very quickly um it has been
challenging
for um some learners more than others
and we've looked to adapt
that bringing learners and we've had
we've had an on-site provision right
through the covet period
for um learners that required
particular support or were vulnerable or
were
children of key workers and so we had
that provision
on site right throughout we've adjusted
the extent of the blend across the
course of the
year according to external conditions
and also monitoring about
how our learners engage with their their
learning um
digital um poverty
um broadband access you know is um
has been a concern in this period we
um distributed i think 200
um wi-fi dongles
for our learners as well as um
we i think we bought 450
additional laptops to give to learners
to
use so we've um this is about making
sure that um
everyone was able to access the learning
that was
provided community support um in the
the earlier phases we gave across a
whole floor of one of our buildings if
you've ever been in our tour restaurant
the ground floor of that which was where
our
barbering and our um uh our salons were
that was turned over to the nhs they
created it as a
um as a hot um
a covered kind of hot zone where they
would have gp treatment
for and those people with covered wasn't
needed in the end so we turned it back
again after we came out a lockdown
but this was us sort of saying as soon
as we saw we had space and we were gonna
be we said
our role as a college is to make sure
that we can do what we can for our
community
we also created space for training of um
covered volunteers um which was done at
tiverton and
um in uh um at our north devon site
and there have been opportunities in
through this
um it has been
a difficult period it's been very tight
financially you may have seen nationally
half of the further education colleges
in the country
are subject to
financial intervention because of the
financial difficulties there and we are
not one of those
but it you know it has made money very
tight because we haven't like
schools received funding for um the some
of these
kind of covered measures and things we
had to find those for ourselves
but there's also been great opportunity
um uh
through this the way that i think our
staff have responded the kind of team
ethos that has been built
has been really positive there's a kind
of unfreezing in terms of practices and
a
willingness to learn new ways and better
ways
of supporting learning that has been
really encouraging uh we
just as we went into the first lockdown
we were doing our
um staff satisfaction survey and some
people said to me well
we shouldn't do it now because
everyone's worried and grumpy and
um but we said now we're going to do it
because then we'll learn from it and we
can take some actions
but um we've done it two years previous
we were 77
satisfied at that point we're 92
satisfied in terms of uh
our staffing we then use the learning
from that to um
work out where we could go next um
there has been some um i say some some
difficulty there is some adversity
apprenticeships has been a key
thing where um
employers just closed down really in
terms of their apprenticeship
operation they weren't taking on new
apprentices they didn't know what to do
a number of businesses were
you know we've seen the number of
businesses that have have gone bust that
was a
has been a real um concern also i said
to the importance of work
for our learners um
work placement is key that has been an
element that
hasn't been able to be um taken forward
during the
the covered period we've done simulated
work
environments but not able to do that you
know i think
it's as good as actually being in a real
organization
um picking up on some of the questions
uh
say that you mentioned mental health uh
we
uh we monitor this very um
very closely and for our learners mental
health
and their physical health as well has
been an issue
um you'll probably know from other um
reports that you had domestic violence
has gone up significantly there are
children in those houses we saw an
increasing number of referrals
um because we get notified by the police
if they've had to
um visit a house um
student mental health has been um
difficult i think we've seen
a um a doubling
this year and the doubling the previous
year of safeguarding incidents
and that we saw we have a safeguarding
team which we
enlarged to support those learners and
we have resources for
um mental health we have counsellors and
people for them to uh talk to
um but it's it has been a has hit young
people really
hard i i think and um
the different yes
go ahead um doubling the doubling um
of numbers um with the safeguarding team
what was the best number prior but no
it's good
yeah good question in a year we um went
from
we had about uh 250 uh
uh safeguarding incidents that rose to
450 and then rose to 900.
and um we we have a system of logging
all of these on
a shared system which is shared with
other you know agencies as you
as you would expect but um you know some
real concerns about
um learners that are considering
self-harm
sorry um you want to follow on the
question there please
cursor laws
uh yes i i actually want to go back a
step
because you were talking about um
companies not relocating here etc
i mean that might that may well change
because who wants to pay
huge rents to be in a city when we're
going to have empty
business properties down here but what
what i really want to know is you've
you're obviously
responding very quickly to covid
are you also responding to the fact that
many many
companies are now are finding that they
want to work with
with their employees working from home
now this must be a huge opportunity
for our community which is renowned to
be very poor
um to train children
in aspects not children young adults an
aspect
of working online and isn't there
um isn't it the possibility of you
actually teaming with
companies not necessarily from this area
approaching
them saying look we've got a new
workforce available
they're young and they they're free
thinking
and actually embracing companies and
trying to
get them to offer that type of
apprenticeship
because we're not locked in beautiful or
barnstable or just horridge
we now have the worldwide possibility
i'm looking at trying to
broaden the availability for your
students to get
first-time employment which may be
working from home
but it's a start so i don't know if i'll
put that very well out
no i i get you exactly i think it's a
really good really good point there's
those things
it's about the kind of the how
how's the landscape change and how would
you create opportunity for
um both for our area economically but
also for our young people
and within that we have digital skills
as an element of
every learner's um program um
in addition to the fact that they're
learning through digital uh means
as part of this i think the you you're
right those opportunities are uh
around them using their digital skills
in different ways in different kind of
areas is a is a really strong one we i
was
we have a dragon's den session with our
business
um enterprise students we looked a new
program around
and creating new businesses
for learners and the numbers of those
they were creating digital businesses
environmentally focused ones they were
looking at markets that were
um not just you know locally they were
thinking well where
where can we sell this from you know
where can we sell this too and i think
that
that reach is a is a very good point i
think the other
dimension is that thing of we'll see
people coming and locating here who are
still connected with other organizations
in other parts of the
of the country and um so
we are working we have a center for
technology innovation excellence which
is a rapid prototyping center
and digital um design center for
um entrepreneurs we that is connected to
node which you'll be familiar with
a joint development um of dodge district
north devon district council and um uh
devon county council
um of creating co-working
connections and i think there's
something about how if we've got a
number of people who are
um working in the way that you you
describe how do we
network those together so that you
create some positive effects and they
can kind of work together in teams
but i think there's also it plays into
how we think about our towns
as places where people may post covered
come
into to make those connections and you
know develop the
um the the kind of the links the kind of
cafe culture and services
which will need to be um different i do
think in that that
you're being able to improve our
broadband infrastructure will be an
important dimension and i know we're
um i think you know we're all on with
lobbying for that
yeah well i i should say in terms of our
own stuff we've got
um those opportunities about being able
to use people from
uh elsewhere i've got one member of
staff who is based in the united states
at the moment
i've got another member of staff who
lives in bedfordshire
um they're doing their jobs perfectly
well
um at the moment and they're not
actually here um
physically they happen to be moving at
some point um
here but it kind of has opened some new
opportunities for us
i mean just looking chair if i may just
looking at the
the retail section section i mean i was
quite shocked because i
obviously haven't been demandable uh
recently but i was there this afternoon
and i walked down through the high
street and it really
brought it home we do have to look
online i mean i run a very small
online business um but i wouldn't be
solvent today if i was just relying on
my shop
and this sort of magnified is exactly
what i i can see you're looking at
it seriously um thank you no no no
and i i i do think together we need to
think about how we
reinvent the high streets um if retail
if retail is not going to return in the
same way we need to think about
how our towns are vibrant places and
what we you know what what's in them
to make that happen we um we're working
with
uh the tourist addition council on the
globe hotel
project for instance in uh torrington
looking at how that may become a
training hotel
and a kind of living kind of you know
it's at the early stages of
of that but i think you know thinking
differently about those
um towns and and village spaces and
you know what we do in them is going to
something i'm sure that we're going to
have to
look at yeah thank you um
sure i guess the issue again i'm sorry
um go around in that circle but just
aware of some of the
of the difference you may be facing up
there um
you said it was 900 uh safeguarding
incidents you had
okay um how many on your student role
can i just
get that yeah no we we have about we
have 10 000 learners in total
and there's about um three and a half
thousand sixteen to eighteen year olds
um the rest are um adults and we have
some that are distance learning as well
and coming
short um so so so
the safeguarding is within the three and
a half thousand within the three and a
half within the three and a half
thousand but yeah
yeah so one in four effectively then is
is that
have i picked up yes so it's so it's
safeguarding incidents so
rather than safeguard safeguarded people
as it were so we may get multiple
incidents with particular people
what we tend to do is you know
particularly where
students are at risk of self-harming
there will be a higher level of contact
with them
to make sure that we're you know we're
aware and so that may be a a number of
kind of logs in
in that because i i mean reading some of
the statistics i gather it's the highest
killers of young males
it is it's the suicide rates at the
present moment and
i think you you i mean you'll be very
aware of that um
and i'm really impressed that you're
taking such action you know
to protect in these really challenging
times reaches really
um not only you know they anxious about
the future but they're isolated to be
anxious about
the future if you follow i mean yeah
wonderful modern communication
um but it is an isolating communication
because we ping an email
without actually seeing somebody it's a
strange time we live in the older
generation when you used to pick up a
telephone
um very seldom does the phone ring any
longer
to hear you doing that safeguarding i'm
really impressed like
thank you for that i don't see how you
know get your rhythm back again
fire away okay thank you i'll
karen a bit yeah no no
apprenticeships uh the um just in terms
of i i mentioned the
um uh there
um it's the
a number of the apprenticeships in um uh
in northern devon relate to um
engineering um
companies they have
been reticent about taking on additional
apprentices so we've seen some
kind of recovery in numbers slowly and
it's coming back now
there are additional financial
incentives from government um
but um it it
it really hit that area of our well that
area of our business as well
um and of course if you haven't got them
started you haven't got them for next
year and so the planned growth that we
had
is a challenge for us i think we are
again looking at how we create the best
experience for those apprenticeships and
adopting the same
approach that we have to 16 18 year olds
where you create a kind of study program
and you say well here are the
enhancement activities here are the
um the digital um skills piece here is
the
you know the the taught subject kind of
content you get here's the project work
we're doing that same thing with
apprentices and with our adult learners
the employment as i say has been
really tough there are a number of
learners who depend on their part-time
employment
paid employment that they would get
to kind of survive and
that in many cases that casual work
dried up
um and they um you know rather than
getting furloughed they were
just kind of laid off uh we
we did see um poverty as a
a problem for a number of learners we um
the free school meals at issue in
schools
um a number of people are not wearing
colleges uh
we still have a number of learners that
get the same free school meals to
support but we
didn't receive that support for over
particular
um holiday periods we from the college
perspective
um continued to make those payments to
learners
and again that there was a the way that
government had thought about this was a
very kind of city-centric
model they said you can have a voucher
for tesco's
or asda if you want to we said well a
lot of our learners
are in villages it's their local shop
that they need to be able to spending
their
money in and so we made sure that we put
the um
we gave the money to them so that they
were able to use it to
um buy the food that they needed where
they could get it
um the work placement opportunities i
say have been
um our learners have not had those
employment experiences a related thing
is that
particularly for those um subjects
where the hands-on experience is
important for learning new skills what
they do in the workplace or they come
into college and they get that
those were areas where they
they weren't able to get as much
hands-on experience in workshops
during covert because you couldn't do it
with the social distancing
um sufficiently we're now kind of
playing catch up with that to try to get
them through but that's been quite
challenging
you asked about how somebody asked about
higher education impacts i can
say obviously petrol we deliver
everything from
kind of entering pre-level one through
to level six which is a bachelor's
degree
uh our learners uh have
in terms of the student satisfaction so
we've done focus groups with them and we
survey our
um students they've been quite positive
about the blended learning experience
they've had so we've
continued to bring them in because we uh
one of the features of our approach is
that we offer
um small group sizes and so we were able
to do those in a socially
distanced way that was safe but we also
as i say
delivered digital learning as well and a
number of
our learners tend to be slightly older
um
they might have children and or caring
responsibilities
their centers don't go back to
dragging me into college every day you
know i want it for some things and i
don't want it for others
and um but so um so we have they have
had
for the patriot learners some
face-to-face experience
um the i know for the university of
plymouth is our validating partner
um it has had an approach
it's what it's called it's safety net
around assessments which gave
learners opportunities to um
to succeed as much as the kids do
um within the constructs because they
hadn't necessarily could have had all of
the learning that they needed
um to undertake but i'm uh
i'm i'm less clear about those learners
who actually traveling to plymouth for
that i know about ours our learners and
and what they got
uh
shall i go on if i you know
little hands in front of me at the
moment you're free
and uh my final
slide was about because you asked about
how um
both about the future but also about
ourselves and torres district
um council um working together in
partnership i have to say had a really
positive working relationship close
links uh
with the council a number of levels both
from um leader
to chief executive and to officers
they've been
positive they've been responsive when we
have
um said you know what can we do about
this and i think also forward-looking
about
i'm thinking of ideas about where we go
to next
um where we go to next i'm really
we've got to tackle the lack of social
mobility and the disadvantaged post
covid uh petra
we we work with the secondary schools
across uh the whole of northern devon
and um
i'm really pleased to say that they are
coming together now being galvanized
rather than
um on the nobody listens to us it's so
unfair
saying actually we're going to set the
agenda for how we're going to change the
fortunes of young people and we're going
to take that out to
our mps to the regional schools
commissioner
to devon county and say this is our
agenda you share this these aspirations
this is what we want to do and so um
that group the nordab group is coming
together there
um coming out of kovid again around
those issues i've
we've had a meeting with um biddeford
college
and with ilfra kum and college so the
three of us are the
um all provide 16 to 18 education
obviously biddeford and and alfred it's
learners that continue to go on who
perhaps
and petroc's not the right experience
for them you know in in previous times
has been a kind of competitive
relationship because clearly that you
know the learners could go to one or the
other
but we've come together and said uh
right for this point now the learners
are typically going to be
leaving school at ma at the may half
term
um what do we do to make sure that they
continue to be engaged in learning and
how do we offer them opportunities for
the next
age in the learning because you know
it's been really disruptive they've not
adopted the patterns of
of learning in many cases and a lot of
the schools are saying to us
we've got 30 20 40
different different schools learners who
are not engaged in anything really
they're not
um they haven't made an application they
don't they're not
thinking about work or anything so we're
focusing together really on those and
we're going to be um
running a program of activities which
will um
be available as tasters for the next
stage of their learning to make sure we
get that transition and people can get
back to um
back to thinking about their their
future rather than those issues around
kind of mental health so um
we need to focus on their aspirations
and raising those
going on the opportunities that they've
got skills development i think is
key to um growing uh a successful
economy here to supporting productivity
and and we're about creating
opportunities for that so
we um again i'm conscious this is being
um
streamed on on on youtube but it's fun
we're just about to go um
uh live with a a new university level
uh education office offer in uh
northern devon where we provide um
paid we provide cash to the learners
our higher education learners and
quality work because there's research
that shows
if learners do are involved in work
related to their um degree they get
better quality
outcomes they get a better job at the
end of it um so we're doing that
providing paid work for um learners not
at the college we're doing it through
um finding on the placement and then
we'll be providing them with um cash as
well
um to support them to be able to do
their learning um
we need to work and we are we have a
package of unemployed workers
support for unemployed workers that's
both where businesses go
um kind of go under and we say okay how
do we you know here's a range of courses
to get people to rapidly
upskill we have uh we've looked with
government's created a number of
initiatives and they're a bit
scattergun at the moment but we're
making
with with other partners um trying to
make some sense and coherence out of
them so for instance
the kickstart package you know so new
jobs as you know six months
um government pays a salary at some a
minimum wage 25 hours a week
and we've created a wrap-around package
to say it's not just about six months
and then you're on the dole queue again
um come in here and here is the range of
training so you can get the skills that
you need to be really valuable
and that to it to lead to sustaining
influence
so yeah go yeah i understood kickstart
was
the only guarantee you had at the end of
kickstart program
was one interview and didn't
guarantee it have i misunderstood the
kickstart
approach john no no that's exactly it
um the you
you might argue from treasury that it's
about just taking people out
of the unemployment market holding them
somewhere for a bit
until the economy recovers and then the
economy can absorb those
stuff was one i went but yeah we're
saying there is an opportunity here
to make sure that you can help develop
them
as employees because otherwise as you
say they do their interview oh what have
you done well i've been making the tea
for six months and being it's gonna
general because nobody really thought
about what i could be doing
and so we've got that that's available
to the um
the employees that come through any of
the kickstart program we've also created
um over 30 kickstart job opportunities
at the college ourself
as well because we think that's a good
way of of supporting them we
we have a package of pro of development
coaching
for those people that come for work with
us um
we the college i haven't said very much
about it we have a large
um project funded um activity base we
have
um lottery funding we have um european
social fund european regional
development funders it
existed a range of charitable funds
we've got a big program there about
those young people who are not in
education
and employment and training and we have
dedicated stuff we can go out
and spend time with those young people
understand why it is that they're not
engaging what the issues are for them
which will be different for every person
if they're in that situation
and um so we've got um work around those
and with we're thinking they're going to
be more of those people
because there'll be some people that are
thinking
oh yeah i'm going to go into work in
september now they might be able to get
a casual job when
we see a load of tourists arrive over
the summer but then that might
drop again of course economically in our
part of the world here
the economy is looking really as you'll
know um
yourselves really kind of
volatile we've got some a lot of
concerns so i think we're going to need
to have
to have that kind of safety net of
support for them
um again unemployed workers we're
looking at there's
there are opportunities coming through
from government
um around adult skills entitlement
not unfortunately in terms of until 2020
um for that uh from government funding
that's going to be available but there's
there's some things
now so we're gearing up with that to say
what's our adult experience and
helping adults to reskill and we have a
big
programme around health and care sector
dedicated towards supporting learners
who are retraining to take jobs in
health and care
because there are jobs there they're
recruiting some of those are really good
quality well-paid
jobs there's a big demand for nurses for
instance and
have associated professionals with
looking to create a ladder there that's
a dev and wide project
um business innovation and productivity
i've talked a bit about this
we've got an innovate uk project where
actually we use students
to um do some of the knowledge transfer
the technology transfer
um with businesses that need to innovate
and we plug them into a network of other
um higher level
support organizations like the
universities but they start off with a
kind of
a not very threatening conversation with
some of our students who are doing
business
um i've talked about the school to
college progression
opportunities that we need to do um you
know i'm
keen to work with all organizations as
we
come out of covid around work and work
experience
loads of young people have lost that
experience if organizations can create
it we've we've
got a team of uh was one person now four
people
focusing on creating meaningful work
placement opportunities for
our learners across all of our programs
um
and we are about um messages for young
people is you know we're
um we will we're going to be living with
covert for a bit but we are able to
create great experiences for them
from september this has been you know it
hasn't suited everybody this kind of
blended learning period
undercover but i think as we come out
it's about getting them excited about
their learning because
we know that somebody who has a level
three qualification
on average is paid better than one who's
level two a level four better than a
level three a level five but
it's a linear link so the further we can
get our learners through into the higher
levels they can get
the better economically it is um for
them
um community rebuilding i said we with
um the district council are working on
um
postcovid business recovery we're doing
that across northern devon as um
partners so with north devon district
council as well
um there is a new policy concept there's
a white paper
skills for jobs which
recognizes the roles that colleges play
as the kind of glue and the connection
between a number of different
organizations
that are able to bring universities in
um when you've got businesses that are
needing them and also as we've seen in
covid that are there
for their communities um working with
the other anchor institutions like the
councils like the hospital
like the police of course to create a
wider and better um
place for us for us all to live and so
you know if i can
there's a message to leave you with you
know we are um
a responsible and committed partner for
northern devon we want to put the effort
in
there and very keen to continue to work
with the council
um on that uh which
takes me to my last um
so that is our agenda petrol excellence
through landing
very good so thank you very much a
lovely picture of a
sunset must be looking at it towards the
bar i suspect
yeah so there we go incredible images we
can create any questions committee
any questions counselors
coach hawkins hi
thank you that was that was great it's
um it's really encouraging when you hear
the type of work you're doing i was
actually speaking to somebody today um i
haven't got all the
or the facts uh
but what they were saying is they were
they were suffering from basically
mental health and their gp
referred them to petroc uh he's uh 60
years old
and never thought that he'd be doing
something like art
um and he said it's actually probably
one of the best things
he's ever done and it's really really
helping i was just wondering
um have you for that type of instance
since lockdown
um have you seen or or do you anticipate
that there will be a lot more people
trying to
to do that type of thing uh
it's a really interesting we've had a
program um called
art on prescription which had been
running for
for some time and it kind of dipped
because government took all the money
away um
uh from it um but i do think
as as you've just said that there is
going to be a um i haven't got figures
on this at the moment
but it's not something that uh yeah i
can
pull off easily but it does relate to
us thinking about the gender around
health of course is of
the integrated health agenda is about
keeping people
healthy rather than treating them when
they're ill
and there's a whole piece in there
around social prescribing which i think
is religion which this is a kind of
dimension of
where you've got a range of
experiences which are not you know it's
not about taking pills or
even doing you know physical exercise of
them but saying think about doing this
which is a voluntary activity uh
thing and so we have we've got some of
that in our offer
i i would increasingly like us to do
we're looking at whether we might create
a course in social prescribing
so that we can get people trained up to
be able to do more of that because it's
a kind of
it's a voluntary activity that people
people do and is growing in
importance so i'm really interested that
you you know you had that referral
any other questions carl are you happy
with the council hawkers you're happy
with the answer there
i am yeah thank you very much um yeah i
think i know a couple of people might
like to do a social prescribing
course so yeah i'll keep an eye on
thank you uh our independent member phil
topham
yes sean thank you for that um
it's it's sort of mental health in
general and as you say
it's about keeping people healthy rather
than perhaps ideally waiting until they
get
unwell i wonder to what extent
um relating to covid but just
generally in terms of the learning
experience
that he how can i put this
uh as learning self
management mental health skills is sort
of integrated into
other learning experiences that people
have i'm thinking about
sort of self-management skills for in
the workplace of course
interpersonal skills you know managing
yourself time management those kind of
things
but more general skills like emotion
regulation
um and interpersonal skills which are
helpful in a range of settings
and and my experience of education is
that they
the the sort of cognitive and the
emotional tend often to be separated
and in extreme cases you know
counselling services end up with the
people
who are unhappy but the academic
part of the institutions don't perhaps
focus as much as they could do
on helping people to build um a sort of
psychological resilience
which will work for them in employment
and in the workplace and i think that's
particularly i mean interestingly
um counselor law's question about online
working at home
one of the issues about that is that
working at home for new new employees
new young employees and trainees
doesn't work very well because actually
you do need some face-to-face
supervision you do need that sense of
personal support there so if you were
going to have young people working at
home you would want to be sure
that they were pretty resilient about
working on their own
and about managing you know managing a
job
from that sort of setting so i'm
wondering about the integration of
good positive mental health into the
education curriculum
and i think that would be true for
people of all ages young people as well
as
adults coming back a long question but
i'm not the gist of it and and
yeah absolutely and it does feature as
part of um adults
i talked about us uh reshaping our adult
offer what we're looking at there
is um having adult um success coaches
and
a lot of those things those barriers
that people face that are not that they
they intellectually haven't got the
ability to learn
distance but there's a they lack
confidence there might be some of those
those kind of resilience things that
stop them taking those
those steps and that you know we see
them start and then
fall over at a particular point so we're
trying to address that with adults
within our
16 to 18 program we have a
a curriculum for tutorial um which is
has within it positive mental health and
resilience is a key
thing of it and when i talked about the
um those
uh the underpinning skills for the life
chances our second aim around life
chances
and employment we have um
an approach where uh learners can do
activities that enable them to
develop one of five personal skills
and um so that they that gets evidenced
and then they
they they then get a certificate if
they're able to show the full range of
personal skills across the
piece and that's the idea there is that
you've got within that
um some of that kind of grit piece than
that um
uh how to deal with mental
the mental health issues that learners
might have as part of the curriculum
there
moving forward so i we just started
working with an american company
called civitas learning that's worked
with hundreds of
community colleges and universities um
using let's say big data modeling
about all of the touch points of a
learner with the
um college so that you can identify
which learners
are um at greatest risk
of not achieving their their results and
not persisting with their studies
i've been involved with a project on on
this where they did the same thing at
looking at
uh students mental health and
it did it in relation to both the
critical self-harm
end where um this was in universities
two-thirds of
um learners who commit suicide had never
come into contact with the specialist
services before they did
but there are patterns in their behavior
that you could pick up through some of
this
this modeling so i think there's an
interesting development and we're
starting with that around the learning
things but i we will move on to
that beyond it um i i think there's also
we i said we do special educational
needs
particularly well and
that's been reflected also in the
growing numbers of learners who choose
the name
petrarch if they have a state an
educational health and care
plan that's an approach to
personalization
thinking about a particular learner and
all of the things that could
help them to succeed that we are going
to be taking for
all of our learners um
within this planning period i haven't
got it straight away we have a
center for learner engagement that is
reshaping around
learner engagement and success and so
when the learner is working with us
we're kind of saying
where are you going to long term you
know i think there's been a tendency
because the money used to come in in
short bits
that the college is focused on right we
need to get them through this 12 months
because that's we get paid other we
don't get paid if we don't do that
and that rubbed off on the learners i
think in
the past where they think i'm just doing
you know what you're doing i'm just
doing this level one bricklaying
course but it's about saying to them
okay well where do you want to go do you
want to be an architect
or do you want to build low carbon homes
in you know
in northern devon somewhere and getting
them to think a bit further ahead and
then us having a plan about how we
we help them with it um
and so that the skills i think of
how you personalize the learning
experiences and think about individuals
and you know all of us have got
complex different needs rather than
saying those people are special all of
us especially in one sort of way you
know i might have confidence issues
they might have a physical disability
they might not have any work experience
we want to take that approach across the
full range of things that we think are
going to help learners to succeed
can i have a follow-up on that sean
so do those kind of conversations
would they actually take thinking in
terms of raising aspirations
people not in education and training
social mobility
surely those kind of holistic
conversations about the person
rather than just the education course
are going to be very important because
there are people who think well
higher education is not for me you know
yeah and unless and yet those people may
have dreams and aspirations
as you say and that and it's having an
opportunity to have those conversations
which presumably can happen at you know
secondary school
as well before people get to petrol but
yeah definitely and i should have said
our reach into the schools
uh has meant that last year the year 11s
you know they got their center assessed
grades and they were
what what were the schools doing they
didn't really do anything we
put on a um a thing that we called
petroc pace which created around maths
english and sciences gcse a
it used artificial intelligence to
personalize both the learning
and teaching methods and the content
according to what the learners
um wanted and that was they really liked
that the learners they continued to
um use it and the schools liked it as
well because it
kept these learners engaged and helped
them with the next transition so we're
kind of
reaching in to the earlier stages as
well as
um we're just about to go into you know
focusing on the progression for our
learners you know if we got them in as
level two
we need to be pinning them down and
saying
where do again where do you want to go
who would you want to be as a person
well that's going to require you to go
this sort of route or that yeah
and i do agree with you it's not all
just knowing the courses and the courses
it's about
uh things about confidence about what
are your lifetimes yeah that whole
person
and i think that um that includes that
kind of inclusive approach that holistic
approach
is something that i would like us to
learn
more about and apply across all of our
um provision
thank you sean very helpful yeah okay i
i should say i'm on staff mental health
we did a under lockdown we did a staff
mental health day
we had a really good day people we had
some
um kind of continued professional
development things that they require but
everyone had to do something
everyone had to get out of their house
or their office there was people we've
got a staff facebook page that was
created
that's really active right through the
the period people showing
pictures of their dogs and you know
making cakes and that so
we bought also a thing called unmind um
which is a package uh of
um mental health support but you you
could you kind of log your own progress
it then pushes you particular things
and there's somebody who sometimes finds
it difficult to sleep i've found that
really useful just on a personal level
because a few tools and i can listen to
the sounds of the waves on the beach and
that gets me off to sleep quite nicely i
found
i'll try that though one day
any further questions i'd see no hands
there
okay i would have thought sean if i can
i was interested
yesterday would have our internal over
overview and scrutiny committee
and we have our quarterly business
reports and this one was up to the end
of september
2020 it was highlighting people on
universal credit
um interesting um a lot of statistics
that came through there and
those nothing worked there was three
thousand and thirty four
nothing work on universal credit in
torridge
and two thousand one hundred and ninety
five in working still on universal
credit now that made
five thousand two hundred given that
torrid is sixty five thousand people
that's about
one and thirteen one and eight of the
population which i find an
absolute staggering sort of situation
really when you actually
number it down and try to nail it and
what i'm also frightened about and you
talked about getting better broadband
because it lets our house prices up and
we're looking at a ten percent
increase in house price now before we
started covered we were looking i think
about one and eight or one and nine
ratio through average earnings to
average house price
all of a sudden with more people on the
lower
social economic scale we talk a lot
about leveling up
um we're going to see housing costs
goes a lot higher and i can see it 10 or
15
by the end of the year with the lower
social economic groups not being
able to earn a lot more than above
national living wage basically
and i just wondered how that was going
to pan out and how that fits with
sometimes with some other self-employed
people
you're sometimes i think putting money
to work you're just to stay at work you
know they don't actually
earn anything at all and they've
with productivity if you follow the the
the situation
and i wonder you know given that we are
a lot of small businesses down here
um and you always want to get hold of
not the employee
but the employer to get some education
about
you know how i can sit back and run a
business
more productively to to to earn some
money here i just wondered if you could
comment
you know that sort of framework we are
now living in sean
yeah i i can i thought it was a really
good analysis
the um you recall our second
uh of the college's aims is around
supporting improvements in the
productivity of businesses
here and that um links through to
um both opportunities for young people
and for
um adults in our community and links
through to learning because i see
businesses that um need to innovate
are just adults that need to learn stuff
and we're quite good at helping
adults to learn stuff for the first time
um but we
but we need to do that explicitly so we
will be bidding in the next month and
for a new government fund announced
yesterday
to create college business centers and
that will be about expanding our range
of services for
local businesses to help them to
think about doing business differently
and as you described there's a lot of
kind of leisure businesses people quite
happy to be
a one-person organization but that
doesn't help our community it doesn't
help those people on
minimum wage who get by on casual work
um kind of in in the summer um we want
to create something more sustainable for
them and i think that starts with us
building businesses that people want to
employ people
and can think actually if i could get
somebody that's got those skills
i've seen an example of the way that you
know um
i know in the midlands that that that
meant that they could grow their
business really substantially as they
started to trade with croatia or
something on
you know they i think we can we need to
do that as a college
and i think we're less threatening than
you a lot of the productivity discussion
up until now around
businesses has been we need to go to a
university and get some high-end
research
now you know on there you know
universities in their kind of ivory
towers have a bit of an image problem
you know the um people don't want to go
and say you know i'm not really sure
about how to do this and my business
isn't going quite
how i want to and whereas colleges
because you know as we
in our introduction we've all been
through colleges we've all got
connections with colleges and they're
more of the community and i see a real
that's why they can be a gateway for
people into a new world of
changing their businesses and also
learning for themselves
excellent thank you very much any other
questions any other comments from
from our committee i see
no hands is there any recommendations
our committee would like to say
or sean would you like to say anything
in return
about what uh you would like to see from
torridge oh sorry christopher james has
got his hands up here
coaster james thank you chair i've got
to go to another meeting though so thank
you for letting me
join in with this one i would like just
to say to sean mackey
we are working together on different
futures and on other things
and it's it's exciting to work with
somebody with such
positive drive um for the benefit of our
wider community
and i look forward to working with him
more and i look forward to bringing it
to
perhaps um a full council or something
of what we're actually doing because at
the moment
it's embryo stuff um we're trying to
develop it but it is exciting it's very
positive for our
area and i'd just like to say thank you
sean i've enjoyed
listening to you um i'm sure we've got
meetings coming up shortly yeah
and so it'd be great to see you then so
just thank you to everybody
my apologies i must go on to another
meeting
thank you linda thank you ken no thank
you for your comments
okay i really enjoyed working with you
with you as well yeah
there's there's a lot i think we're a
really good point for northern we
yes we know that we've got some real
yeah a lot of our community got some
real issues
but we can through um
working together using our combined
influence bring some resources into
um northern devon you know if government
with a leveling up agenda and then you
look at
you know i think torridge has the lowest
average
um wage of any um
district in the country i think and
you know then if you're not going to
level up here and make some investment
here then where are you
you know so that gives us something so
to play back into
national level and and you know
when it goes together with the ideas and
the and the positivity that we're
showing across the
the councils and with other partners i
think yeah we've got a lot to go for
right thank you for me anyway
right any other recommendations
glorious record based recommendation
here from our leader
to work together for the future so we've
got that one
um any other broadband i i think was a
really important issue because
now distance learning will be part of
the system
i know archives was very keen to have
connectivity
um and digital exclusion i think your
term was earlier in the meeting was very
important
so so we take that on board and we work
with that
is there anything you would ask if
torrid sean can i ask um from your point
of view
um i i i don't think not beyond the
things that the council's
is involved with i say you know you've
um genuinely i've been um
pleased about the very positive response
that you get from
um officers under the direction of
kendo had some meetings with ken about
the kind of the the wider piece and with
steve as as chief exec
i think us thinking about those
opportunities for work
i would be the the one and if there are
opportunities that council can create
for
work placement or apprenticeships or
traineeships or
you know all of those things it's going
to be really important for
our adults our young people in our
community and i think it's
you know i i know the council's on to
that but i think it's incumbent on all
of us to
um try and do that for our our community
so we echo that as
a comment as well that we recorded for
our minutes
any other any other points anybody else
wants to make or raise
in this uh fantastic presentation
then can i thank you sean again for
your excellent work with the uh
preparing for the future generation and
the work you're doing around it but i
also pick up you know the the comments
about the elderly
and the prescribing agenda as well and
lifelong learning and all the other
issues that go with that thank you for
the work you're doing
and um good to see the austin reports
are still going as as good as they are
for you
um congratulations um and thank you very
much indeed
thank you very much thanks very much for
the opportunity um chair and um
good to be able to talk with all of you
thank you for your questions
thank you very much thank you cheers
stop my sharing you okay yeah i'm just
getting out hang on
when you're all the buttons are pressed
tall
yeah i'm all good thank you i've got 10
minutes of um
time with simon here still with us are
we still poor it's
carl are you still there i am indeed
i got jamie is a blank space at the
moment but um he
probably will arrive again in a minute
so we're just hanging one two
three yeah yeah and we've got eight but
dodgy chair
you're not your chair
uh i'll send you a stump of wood then uh
jamie that's all right i've got some
line around here
okay um is there any recommendation you
is burning you without or shall we leave
that where we can and just go through
the minutes now simon's with us and um
go from there i don't see any hands
don't want to make any further
recommendation
we close that down um
can we then go back to agenda item
number two the minutes on
pages three to eleven
and um i'm looking at the numbers um
in front of me on the bottom of the page
first of all for accuracy
page three four
three yes go to another
you're rooted chris i'm just going to
move the minutes chair
you want to move okay let's uh let's go
move
anybody want to raise any money rising
can stop larry i've got coaching with
the question
okay thank you thank you chairs
it's not um uh it's uh it's just a
couple of
items just to feed back to councillors
from the meetings
um on um on the issues of the play areas
just to let councillors know that um
uh the swings at high view that barbra
shaw said highview was already repaired
um and i raised the fact that it wasn't
um
westbrook housing contacted me um
shortly after the meeting to let me know
the date that it would be done
and it was done then and i've been up
there and seen it and and it's all
lovely the grandchildren have been
playing on it
and on the issue of the bowed and green
area uh i had quite a few residents
here about the fact that bowser and
green was on the list of pa
park areas that might be developed for
housing uh and so i
i didn't i want to waste time in that
meeting discussing with barbara shaw but
i contacted her again
um and she stressed that it was not
definitely going to be built on
there would be further consultation
before it happened
but the consultation would only be with
western tenants particularly
those who pay a service charge and she's
stressed again which you've done in the
meeting that it is difficult
when others use the facilities and have
high expectations
but don't pay any service charge towards
them
so i'm just feeding that back obviously
the bowed and green issue is ongoing
but thank you thank you for that yeah
that's just feedback it's not a
incorrect minute we're not recording it
because
okay um phil topham yeah
page 10 chair item 60 consideration of
the forward plan
third paragraph there's an incomplete
sentence at the end of that paragraph
[Music]
um i think that was related to you chris
i think you
you wanted to ask that question if
remember rightly from the meeting
uh i raised it chad are you racist okay
i
do apologize counselor
when said what he said in the next bit
so i'm not quite sure what the to be
included in that
refers to okay do you want to take the
2v8
philip unless you know what how the
sentence finishes
that'll finish that one can you take
and we've just got that incomplete
sentence at the bottom of 10.
so therefore we've got the proposition
and the second thing um that we
record the minutes as an accurate record
with those uh
with that one alteration can we take a
vote please mary
yes chair councillor harding
four i'm sorry i was late
councillor hawkins four
council langford or
councillor
council mackenzie
councillor newton fourth
councillor pennington or mr tobham
thank you all right we moved from the
minutes then
to uh agenda item number four the action
list which is a list of completed items
um i take it you've all looked at them
and given um
phil topham's comment about last time i
hadn't read that
incomplete sentence does anybody want to
add anything or pick up any minute there
on pages 12 or
13.
thank you mary for all the work i think
they've all been completed
so that's been there we then go to
agenda item and number
nine which is the annual report on pages
14-21
there will be a little bit of addition
though with the petroc comment i take it
mary
that will go in there that's correct
otherwise the report with the amendments
that we agreed last time
are any comments any amendments any
changes i'm happy with it but
i just wanted to hear if anybody else
has
got any comment
then soon as i have no hands and with
the
provider that there will be just the
addition of the pet rock that will agree
with mary if you use a committee will
agree that
we actually i propose this that be our
forward or our annual report that will
go forward to full council
stunning time in the new year i will
second that uh
trap thank you second of course newton
uh can we take a vote mary
yes chair councillor harding or
council hawkins for
councillor langford for
councillor leather or
councillor mckenzie or
councillor newton or
councillor pennington or
mr topham
thank you
right we come then to agenda item number
10
the forward plan i don't propose to
put in anything unless anything's got a
burning issue uh we have 9th of june
um i think we agreed there are the first
of the new cycle the new case so
it's not a slightly wider gap i do
apologize that uh
um i've i called the meeting but i was
asked by the leader
due to pressure on the calendar to bring
the meter forward meeting forward one
week from the 28th of april
to the 21st of april um we have a
meeting there and you then can look at
the forward plan
as you wish for the new year but if
there is somebody
who has something that should be burning
i will listen to it but i
would like the new committee at that
meeting basically to set their agenda
when the
when the new committee meets anybody got
a burning issue
chair no but my apologies i must leave
you now i'm afraid to
join my other meeting simon thank you
very much for your story
okay uh okay i don't see any other
any other hands so we we go and leave
the forward
i'm getting a lot of criticism about um
you know stuff that they should be doing
grass cutting and
maintenance-y type things in the in the
play parts etc
um is that something we can do or is
that just leave it to the next
meeting and uh put it on there it's not
burning but it's something i'll probably
forget if i don't i'll say that
three minutes of yesterday's internal
ons meeting
i think the groundwork for the new
tivoli
contract is put forward there it was all
in part one so i'm not i don't have to
say anything that's not
in the public domain um
a foundation document um and then we're
looking at issues and as i understand it
and station you'll tell me if i'm
incorrect
um that the i i think we'll be looking
to take
in house when the contract comes to an
end in 2022.
i have that impression so yeah yeah okay
yeah fair enough chair
yeah believe it okay
um stacy yes
sorry i put my hand down now really
check because you have discovered it but
yes we are in discussions regarding that
counselor mackenzie but
if there are issues and raise them with
us and then we we
can try and try and assist but certainly
i think as members will know those
discussions are currently
taking place regarding the grounds
maintenance
um and obviously there'll be updates
coming shortly but
if you've got specific concerns over
areas not being done and of course we
can raise that by property so
drop me an email maybe if you want to do
that and i'll raise
them with adrien for you lovely i've got
some other stuff to bring up with you as
well
okay do it all at once then
all right is there any other discussion
on item 10 the agenda item 10 ford plan
any re any red yellow hand sorry yellow
hands
okay then with that i will declare
the meeting closed and we will be seeing
you on monday evening um
for the full council agm so thank you
very very much
um sean's no longer with us so we will
write to sean as well in the due
and due course with a valuation form as
well that will go with that
and keep up the good work there thank
you all for your contribution this
evening i call the meeting to
close at
19 30.